um okay why don't we go next to
nisha from michigan nisha you're on the
air
oh my god uh hi dave how are you doing
i'm doing well thank you okay well
i um i've actually been um looking at
your show on
youtube i'd say ever since 2019.
beautiful i'm pretty much a fairly fan
um
i was also on yesterday but uh i know
you couldn't reach me because there's a
lot of people um
so the whole thing with the uh derek
shoving case i was as
shocked as you were so i
actually didn't even think that they
were gonna do it but i'm glad that they
uh that they did um
uh i don't even know what i could
actually say as a
question because i'm a little i'm a
little bit nervous you're doing great
well listen
let me ask you this what is happening in
michigan
with covid which has been very up and
down
and much controversy over covet
guidelines
yeah i think as of right now
i've even been checking about it myself
so
i mean it's like half and
i guess half and half i was actually
talking to uh one of my
friends i think some days ago and she
said that she was um not really um
thinking about getting the um vaccine
and i pretty much was telling her like
well if you
i already said like if you don't want to
get the astrazeneca one of course yeah
no that's fine because that has blood
clots and also
yeah astrazeneca is not even approved in
the united states did you mean johnson
and johnson
and the johnson johnson one of course is
you know
that too but i had told her that i had
my um i i do have a i did get i'm half
vaccinated so i dig in my um
moderna vaccine along with my husband
and my mother
beautiful so i have pretty much told her
about i
pretty much have told her if you if you
want to go and do either the pfizer or
the madonna vaccine you
can be able to do that and she pretty
much still said that she was uh
skeptical
and what is she skeptical of is she
skeptical that it works is she skeptical
of side effects
maybe it might be because of side
effects
i'm not sure but she had told me that i
think her
auntie and her grandmother had got it
and they were fully vaccinated
yeah and i pretty much said well that's
at least enough proof there they're
still
you know alive and well they're walking
and whatnot so i'm like that could at
least be proof right there that it's
yeah but i mean it's also like you know
hundreds of millions of people around
the world have now been vaccinated it's
weird when it's like
your aunt or something like that my my
approach would be this nisha i would
always say
what is making you hesitant to get it
because sometimes people say i don't
know that i want to get it and it could
range from
i think there's a bill gates microchip
in it to i think there will be long-term
side effects too i don't know that it
works too i don't want
you know whatever so try to figure out
what is the reason for the hesitancy and
deal with that
i don't know because the whole thing the
whole bill gets thing i think that is
way too far fetched because that
just to me does not make any type of
sense i agree with you
yeah i know i know she would not go that
far right
okay okay fair yeah just ask what the
hesitation is
comes from and then deal with that
head-on yeah and she well
and also she had told me that she wanted
to go and wait a year
i was like uh okay yeah i don't think
that's really like a good
i'm not entirely good because i mean
if you want to go in at least well i
kind of don't want to make it
kind of sound like that like pretty much
if you want to go on uh you know
you know for us to hang out again and
whatnot and also go and see um
you know my baby so yeah i mean you know
i mean at least get vaccinated or
something
at least that's maybe some reason i
didn't want to frame it like that
sure and i don't think i even told i
don't think i even told her
it i don't think i told her like that in
that way either so yeah all right well
good
good luck in michigan nisha said it's
going in the right direction but it's
not happening maybe as quickly as we
would like it's actually nisha though
nisha okay i apologize it's okay it's
sorry
nisha a perfect phone call i appreciate
it
thank thank you there is nisha
from michigan